the cofounders of fusion GPS that
research company behind the Trump
dossier I have written on audacious New
York Times op-ed claiming that
conservatives are spinning conspiracy
theories about them and their beneficent
company they demanded Congress released
transcripts of testimony by their firms
members I couldn't agree more maybe then
we'll find out why fusion GPS has
refused to answer key questions or have
its leaders testified publicly but why
stop there tonight I'm calling on the
Trump administration to declassify all
documents and all testimony concerning
the Hillary Clinton email investigation
the Russia probe and the role played by
fusion GPS and the people my friends
have a right to know they have a right
to transparency from their government
unless national security matters are
involved with everything that's on the
line here with all of the doubting about
this investigation and the concerns
let's shed a light on this whole sordid
mess and then we'll see who's really
colluding with whom for more insight
let's turn to a pair of reporters who
have been all over these stories I'm so
happy they're both here that among my
favorite reporters John Solomon of the
hill and Wall Street Journal's Kim
stress all great to see both of you Jon
we got some breaking news tonight from
Devon Nunez tell us House Intelligence
Committee after a surprise meeting at
Kriss ray rod Rosen's team went up the
hill met with Paul Ryan E FBI director
FBI director and Deputy Attorney General
they both showed up at the hill at a
meeting with Paul Ryan a couple hours
later surprise surprise they're finally
gonna get the access to the documents
they've been seeking since August about
fusion GPS Nunez made the announcement
about a half hour ago and everyone's
very optimistic for the first time we're
gonna see some of these documents and
learn a little bit more about what
really went on with the dossier now
Crim's drasil do you think there is a
amazing what the threat of a contempt of
congress action will do to some of these
government officials is that behind this
newfound desire to show documents that
they've been holding back for many many
many months Paul Ryan gets a lot of
credit here I think we just wish he'd
have done it
sooner because obviously this is what it
took these guys have been giving Devin
newness and the Intelligence Committee a
run around since August when the
subpoenas first went out they had all
kinds of excuses all of them
bogus my favorite one was that somehow
they couldn't talk because of an
inspector general investigation as if
that would ever Trump Congress but what
it took was the speaker essentially
saying look if you don't hand these over
you will be brought up on contempt
charges and nobody wants that and it was
the final kick they needed apparently
and let's hope they actually comply this
time and stop with the games and John I
also want to get into this fusion GPS
deal in the New York Times today again
people have to understand that they are
the ones who got their hands on this
Russian dossier been discredited looks
like it could have been used to go after
those FISA warrants they're moaning and
whining that basically they're being put
upon and they want to release
transcripts of their behind-closed-doors
interviews that they did with the on the
hill couldn't they just talk about what
they said I wish they would I think we
would learn an awful lot about their
interactions with the FBI how they took
this political document got into the
criminal justice system
I think we'd also learned about some
things they said about the FBI that
might might be so flattering and we
might learn a little bit about this guy
Christopher Steele and what he was doing
and whether all the things he said in
public are really true about the work
they've done for Russia oh yeah they've
done a lot of work over the years for
Russia including on the Magnitsky Act
that sanctions the very people who were
meeting with Don junior at the Trump
Tower they had a connection to those
people there's an awful lot of things
that we needed to have a lot more
transparency about Kim's trestle that
that Russian lawyer who ended up meeting
at Trump Tower and heard Steve bannon's
comments about that and that new Michael
Wolfe book we saw that excerpt earlier
called it treasonous and unpatriotic we
we have it now we have information that
that lawyer vessel mitts kiya
actually met with the fusion GPS people
as well I mean this that's why I want
all of this Declassified if there's any
classified documents I want this all
release so it's about time this whole
thing wrapped up got to the bottom
of it everybody's card should be on the
table and get this over with
and she didn't just meet with them by
the way she met with Glenn Simpson and
the hours before she went to Trump Tower
and in the hours she left after she left
Trump Tower now he's claiming that
there's no connection between the
dossier and these particular set of
Russians who are connected to the
Kremlin but we need to know all this I
love your idea Laura of Dyck
classification it looks as though
Congress has the ability to do that even
though it hasn't necessarily and it's a
rare thing we have to be very careful of
exposing sources and methods but when
you're at a level this high where you've
got accusations on one side that the
president was engaged in a conspiracy
with a foreign power and accusations on
the other that our law enforcement
agencies were you know in a bad way
tapping Americans using opposition
research documents to launch campaign or
to launch investigations those are as
serious as and accusations and you get
and you don't trust that anymore to a
commission or a Special Counsel you let
the American people see the documents
themselves and work it through
themselves is there anything on
collusion I mean we have all this time
goodbye they've interviewed all these
witnesses brought in lots of White House
officials from the lower staffers to the
upper echelon what do we have the latest
I've heard and I've done a lot of
digging on this there's still no
evidence the president was involved in
collusion they are looking at one family
member and some trips and conversations
he had based on some new information
that Mike Flynn may have provided but we
don't know much more than that but to
date there's nothing in the public that
says as there's collusion you've seen
the Democrats really pull back from
conclusion James clapper yesterday I
think we have a clip I want to share
this with everybody let's watch there
were other factors that I think were the
stimulus for the investigation and and
the revelation about George papadopolis
which was not a name on my radar scope
when I left
Kim Stossel your reaction told clapper
there well so we've been told just
recently by the New York Times that it
was George papadopolis that inspired
this entire
investigation not the discredit dossier
of course just you know last year the
New York Times was saying that it was in
fact the dossier that did it but now
that it's been discredited now it's
George papadopolis so to find out that
the head of intelligence says he doesn't
even know this guy's name he wasn't on
his radar screen at the time that he was
leaving office you know it's it's
another reason to be incredibly
skeptical of the notion that it was some
twenty eight-year-old jr. Trump staffer
that somehow launched an entire FBI
probe it's ridicu